let's talk about football blue 42 this
football right I don't know
today we're talking about this for
soccer
no it's football you have the players
the managers and the tea the tea mr.
Parrish please explain welcome to you
all to Nottingham Forest FC and have a
great time while you're here and don't
forget if you can try a cup of my Tom's
team the best Nottingham Forest is one
of the oldest football clubs in the
world
they had a great run about 40 years ago
winning two European Cups and loads of
other stuff no I'm very proud of this
team happy days but whilst those days
are gone there is still one world class
tradition that remains well my name is
Tom Parrish almost 89 now not belong
before the 90 I'm a tea boy and I love
it people do this a tea boy I said yeah
work my way out here in Britain it was a
common occurrence for football clubs to
have a tea lady or a tea boy sadly these
traditions are on the decline but what
does the tea boy do oh yeah what does
the tea boy do it makes tea of course
so Tom isn't handing out tea at the
sideline he has his own kitchen next to
the team's dressing rooms let me show
you around his job is to make classic
cups of tea for managers players
directors photographers that's one of
our photographers yes here's a good lad
the list goes on so Tom were your top
tips for making tea you get the best tea
and that is Yorkshire tea boiling water
over the tea bag get it to the side of
the cup and squeeze it as much as you
can to get the juice out of the tea bag
put your milk in that should be I hope a
good cup of tea
[Music]
it's not just a football Matty it's
something that you look forward to and
it's there every week that's what keeps
you going and as I said I love it love
it there's long as I can walk and that
the club will have me I won't be here
back in a cup of tea
[Music]
you
[Music]